tonight another tool in the fight
against domestic violence safe nest
teaming up
with the mexican consulate of las vegas
to empower
protect and support victims specifically
those in the immigrant community
christian kosovo is joining us live in
studio with how these organizations will
work together
well brian it's a collaboration that was
long overdue but necessary according to
both safeness and the mexican consulate
they are urging the community to speak
up if there are victims if they are
victims
of abuse now the effort between both
entities was formalized
this morning with the signing of the
moradorium of understanding the goal
is the prevention and elimination of
violence especially in women
and children they say the pandemic
caused an uptick in domestic abuse
cases but they want to remind victims
that help is available in both english
and spanish liz osenberger with the
safeness says domestic violence comes
in many forms not just physical or
mental abuse
here are some examples someone making
financial decisions with
without you are they taking your
paycheck and it all starts out in a way
that
looks very normal right let me have your
cell phone number so that i can make
sure
i can text you during the day and then
it's 20 ticks and then it's 30 texts and
then it's where are you and then
if you're starting to feel anxious that
you're not home on time or you're a
couple minutes later you took longer at
the grocery store and you know there's
going to be a consequence for that
well a big concern according to both
groups is the victim's legal status
personal information will always stay
confidential regardless of citizenship
status now the hardest step they say
is asking for help now the mexican
consulate tells me
there is protection for victims and
their children which may include housing
and financial help so if you or someone
you know needs help please call that
number
right there on your screen 702-646-4981
or visit safenest.org